Vincent: Hi, guys, there has been a lot of big and you in tech industry going out this week.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, some are exciting. Some are depressing The exciting news is that open AI release its latest multi-model Gbd 4 model.
Jeffrey Feng: while less capable than humans in many real world scenarios exhibits human level performance on various professional and academic benchmarks. For example, it passes a SIM simulated by them with a score around the top. 10% of test takers
Jeffrey Feng: in contrast. Gpt: 3.5 score was around the bottom 10%.
Yooni Choi: This is this was so exciting. Can't imagine what Gpt. For can do, since chat you. Pity is so powerful. Already I have been using chat Gp extensively for my everyday work.
Vincent: Gbd. 4 is still powerful, according to open AI Gp for 60 in the most with some public available tasks in the case of Olympics and Ap. Free with lost questions.
Vincent: So by purchasing 2222, 21 is through addition, so practice them as they've been no certificate training for this.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, I think what's more exciting is that Jbd: 4 can even accept visual inputs.
Jeffrey Feng: There was an exam example. On opening a website that user asked for
Jeffrey Feng: What is funny about this image?
Jeffrey Feng: Describe it panel by panel and Gbd. For successfully identify all the interesting features of that image.
Yooni Choi: Given these features, I think it's definitely worthwhile for us to do a deep dive into its capabilities.
Does anyone want to take this task.
Vincent: I can do that for next week. This is actually Anton will be reading openly, I technical report for Gbt for and presented a summary of it to the team.
Jeffrey Feng: Thank you, Dodger. At the same time the bad news in tech industry it then, that has starts another round of layoff since last November, I think, met a plan to lay off, or about 10,000 employees, or, roughly, 13% of its workforce.
Yooni Choi: That's a lot of people I remember that are already laid out 10,000 employees. Last year the layoffs will affect to met us recruiting team this week. What they were structuring of his tech and business groups to come in April and May, Mr. Zuckerberg said in a memoir posted on the company's website.
Vincent: I also heard this layoff involve a lot of methods made to layer manage people.
Vincent: I'm. In Ernest, Con, February. The chief execute that he a doll one I want to be overst with the lay of middle management, our managers managing managers.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, this is an interesting question for us to investigate as well whether too much middle management people is actually helping or hurting the company.
Yooni Choi: It makes sense because I can. Meta has kept changing from metaverse to AI or vice versa. There's definitely something wrong with their leadership structure for next week. Unice action item will be investigating whether the middle management layer is helping or slowing. The company's. Efficiency
Vincent: sounds good, maybe are the tech giants, like Amazon and Google, are experiencing the same problem.
Jeffrey Feng: This was an interesting discussion. Have a good good week, guys.